[تصفيق]
سقوط الصنم وهي ما تعتبر سقوط بغداد وانما
سقوط الصنم يقول فانا اخذت المطرقه هو
شاكوش ورحت فرحان اضرب بالصنعه
اولاد المسؤولين مثلا ابن محمد حمزه يعني
ابن مطبان كلهم
يعني يعرفني شخصيا
[موسيقى]
البطل الاسيوي والعالمي
كاظم شريف حسن الجبوري
اربع بطولات خمس بطلات يعني
بناء سام والافقان
اخذت الاول وهايه يعني
كلش بطوله قويه
وعده يعني ابطال معروفين
وطلعت الاول يعني
بالاضافه الى اسيا ام كذلك يعني ثاني ثالث
اطلال بس
يعني
كلش احتج بها واحبها
الدراجات حوالي 98 99 كنت احور يعني هم
تحوير واحب الهاردي احب الدراجات
اللي محيره
وصارت مهمتي بالدراجات السيارات
هاي الدراجه كان يقودها صدام حسين ايام
النضال سنه الخمسينات
اسمها نورتين
1947 انهزم بيها من العراق الى سوريا
اصلحها دائما يعني
مثلا ابن محمد حمزه يعني ابن مطبان كلهم
كذلك عدي يعني يعرفني شخصيا هو جاي صدام
حسين من انضرب برجله انضرب يعني
والله حقيقه انا من عائله يعني
اكثرهم يعني اخواني وعمي
ماركسيه يعني عشان ياخذوه من عائلتي يروح
بعد انتهت اما ينعدم واما معبد ثلاثه
اربعه حوالي ولد عمي واخوي الله يرحمه
سجنت على
تافهه يعني اخر ايام قمت تمتنع يعني ما من
تصريحهم يجون عليه ما يعني كرهتهم ما
احبهم ما اصلح لهم قالوا بسيطه
مدبره يعني
الحكومه عليه تسع سنين وسويت قاعه بالسجن
قاعه الرياضيه مثل هاي القاعه
يعني هذا احنا جينا تسعه اربعه 2003 كانت
يعني ناس فوضى وفوسه وانا كان اختاريت هذا
التمثال هو اللي هذا
التاريخ هذا المكان كانت امنيتي
امنيتي انا احطهم هذا
كان تجي السياره تكسي من اروح لهاي
السفاره
السفاره الفرنسيه راح اتمرن بهاي القاعه
بيجي يوم
افلش هذا التمثال والله اجى هذا اليوم
واخذت الشاكوش المطرقه
اجيت على الصنم
شباب كلهم يعني ولد الكراده واولادنا
واصدقاءنا يعني
صارت العمليه شويه اسهل بالصخور
عاد وقعنا
فهو سالني قال لي تحتاج مساعده قلت له
اوكي صعد الدبابه الجبس الدبابه مالتهم من
صعدناها فوق
حطينا
خلينا نلعب رقبته وسحبناه من اول مره
انقطع الحبل بعدين
صار محاوله ثانيه انقطع يعني انسحبناه وقع
على هذا
والله كذا اتمنى يعني خلصنا من نظام صدام
الديكتاتوري ندمان على ضرب صنم لانه ندمت
يعني بشكل ما كنا نتوقع نتوقع للاحسن
نتوقع
يعني على
امر الواقع يعني ملموسه يعني